[Music]
gene drives are ways that a gene editor
can be used to spread a genetic trait
through a population quickly and
research lab in California was recently
able to use this kind of strategy to
spread a trait through a population of
fruit flies in a laboratory setting very
quickly and I think what what amazed
many people many scientists was that was
how efficient this was at creating a
effectively a new strain of fruit flies
that had a different different genetic
trait in every individual I think that
you know this this you know potential to
use that kind of spreading of a genetic
trait is is both exciting in terms of
controlling vectors that could spread
disease but it also makes a lot of
people nervous because of the potential
to spread the trait that might become
something that would be deleterious
somehow in the environment so for
example imagine that we're possible to
spread a trait that that wiped out
mosquitos or were you know created a
created a population of insects that
were somehow damaging in the environment
I think that those are those are
applications of this technology that are
very important to discuss and to think
about before we sort of forge ahead and
release animals like that into the
environment so for for for people that
have seen Jurassic Park or if you have
kids like me you've seen it many times
you know it's it's sort of a really
interesting idea sort of this was
Michael Crichton's idea in the in the
book and then in the movie to think
about being able to take bits and pieces
of DNA that come from extinct animals
and somehow piece them back together
perhaps using sequences of DNA from
existing animals to create genomes that
would allow you know once extinct
animals to to be alive again and you
know could that really be done and
and I think that you know the CRISPR
technology offers scientists a tool now
where at least in principle maybe not to
the level of was in the film Jurassic
Park but but you know in principle could
allow introduction of new genes into
existing genomes that would recreate
animals that have traits that have been
lost by extinction and so you know a
number of scientists have been thinking
about this I think George church is one
of the one of the prominent scientists
who's been discussing this in the
context of the extinction of woolly
mammoths you know could you actually
take DNA that's been sequenced from the
remains of woolly mammoths and use
elephant DNA to recreate these animals
somehow and you know it's it's a it's a
sort of a fascinating idea now whether
that would actually work I think there's
a lot of technical challenges to doing
that experiment but could we do things
like bringing back the carrier pigeon or
you know animals that might have been
have gone extinct of very recently and
where we could we have close genetic
relatives that we could actually study I
think it's a you know to me it's a it's
an interesting idea because of the
potential for understanding genetic
networks and the you know what what what
genes are really doing how they how they
really give rise to certain traits I
mean I think that one thing to
appreciate is that in most cases the
traits that we observe in animals or in
ourselves are coming from interactions
with many many genes it's not just one
gene that gives rise to you know
somebody's height or intelligence or
anything else it's really a whole
network of genes better interacting and
to start to understand that I think
would be very exciting and potentially
could be done using this kind of
strategy of introducing genes from
extinct animals back into existing
animals and it's hard to say you know
how soon that will be a reality but I I
think the the potential to learn a lot
about the genetics of living systems is
exciting I think with any new technology
you know the people get excited and
they see opportunities not only for
doing research in the cases of this kind
of science but also for commercial use
and to make a profit and in in the case
of Jean Dr you know this is this is a
tool that could really enable the
creation of organisms that might be
commercially valuable and yet one could
also say well you know there needs to be
close supervision of that close
regulation of release of animals or
organisms like that that are engineered
in such a fashion and I think you know
with any new technology one always has
to try to get the balance rate on the
one hand we of course want to see
technologies and science in general
being used to solve real world problems
real human problems but on the other
hand we want to ensure that that
progress is responsible progress that we
are working together with stakeholders
to ensure that that there's not an
unintended or even a negative intended
consequences of the use of these
technologies how to do that is a big
challenge
[Music]
you